what's up everyone welcome to the
collider interview Studio at Sundance
2024 I am lucky enough to be sitting
with the team behind I saw the TV glow
what an electric Premiere last night
that audience went nuts for your
movie
yes that was really the only response I
needed just like affirmative that is
what happens before we get into our
conversation I have to take a moment to
thank the fine folks at film for helping
us get to Sundance this year filo is
breaking barriers right now by putting
the power in the hands of creators and
fans by giving them the ability to Green
Light project so big thanks to them and
if you want to learn more about filmo
check out their website film IO film.
excuse me all right Jane I'm G to give
you the first question it's the synopsis
question because a lot of our audience
is first going to be learning about your
film via Sundance so would you mind
giving a brief synopsis if that's even
possible of I saw the TV glow because
there's so much to explore in this world
you created I saw the TV glow is a movie
about two lonely teenagers who find each
other through their shared love of a
strange kind of scary kind of sweet Tv
show uh they get together every week to
watch it together um but when their
Obsession kind of gets out of hand their
entire sense of reality kind of gets
called into question you were prepared
for that I'm very impressed been working
on it for a yeah I feel like yeah I've
been trying to figure out a way to
synopsize it for folks who have been
asking I'm like I'm slowly getting there
slowly getting there but question about
making the move from first feature to
Second feature because I feel like
there's a lot about that process that
kind of needs to be demystified so what
is something that you would say is a
misconception about what it takes to get
a second feature off the ground after a
successful first feature but then I want
to know something about your first
feature that helped you get this movie
made and the way you wanted I think that
most people don't really understand the
sort of like strategy of kind of like
the behind the curtains of of the film
industry um and so I think it's all
misconception because I I think that
they don't necess like when I went to
film school I didn't learn about how to
get a movie made I learned maybe how to
make a movie kind of but I didn't quite
learn um anything about like the entire
sort of like commercial capitalist
infrastructure built around uh
filmmakers and Movie Makers and so I I I
I think there's really no difference
between the first short film you make
the 10th short film you make the first
feature you make the second feature you
make because I think in all cases you
are interacting
with uh for-profit commercial industry
and you as an artist are choose in how
how to engage with that towards like
whatever ends you might have so I think
like I chose to make my first feature
for almost no money so I could have
complete artistic freedom and that
helped me get a second movie made that
also
had uh I I think I had an unusual amount
of artistic freedom to make this movie
uh because I had sort of proven my voice
with the first feature but I think there
are a million ways to make movies you
know I know people who make movie every
year for no money uh so I think it's
really like to me the most important
question rather than waiting for a green
light is just like finding your voice
and what you need to say if you're an
artist and then figuring out how to sort
of um be a spy in the you know to The
Gatekeepers who hold the power to to get
cool made be a spy to get cool
made I like that um I'll build on that
just briefly because you did mention
that last night I think it was during
the the introduction just how great it
was having a24 as a partner and them
giving you the opportunity to to make
the movie that you wanted to make as
bold and daring as it is what is
something about the way they collaborate
with their artists that you really
appreciate it and you're excited for
more upand cominging filmmakers with
bold Visions being able to experience
when they work with them in the future I
just I just think that a24 has managed
to Brand themselves as like the place
where at least in
America uh you're going to see something
that you don't expect you're going to
see something that's like defined by its
difference from the
mainstream
um I think it's become like colloquial
in like Hollywood right where people are
sort of like I want to be in an a24 type
movie and so like that kind of power of
of of like the the quote unquote brand
signifying something new or something
different or something a little bit
transgressive is obviously really
exciting when you're an artist trying to
do exactly that so I you know when I
sort of after my first film which again
was a very micro budget very small film
uh did pretty well here at Sundance a
few years ago I knew that like the dream
come true would be getting to make you
know my like sophomore future with a
company like a24 a24 movies being
defined by their difference is something
I'm going to remember and repeat at some
point I will toss a question to the two
of you now because I'm sure the script
for this movie was wonderful but when I
watched something like this and just
like how how distinct the atmosphere the
vibe the colors literally everything is
it makes me think it might be difficult
to fully picture what this world is
going to look and feel like based on the
page and the page alone so what were
some of your biggest burning questions
for Jane when the script first came your
[Music]
way I I had a bunch I just I've read it
a few times through before before I felt
like I really got it like all the way um
and I was I would say I was hounding you
a little bit about for answers just uh
yeah and well to to to answer the
question about the atmosphere part I do
feel like it was it I could not have
like realized what I was walking into
when I got on set and there was like the
ice cream truck with the pink smoke and
all that stuff but the script was pretty
descriptive like there was a lot of that
um visual stuff already there which is
cool yeah I had I had a lot of questions
trying to think of a specific I mean I
don't I don't want to give anything away
about the movie but um deeper deeper
meaning questions I mean even after
watching it I still have a lot of
questions and I think that's one of the
most exciting things in the world being
left with questions wanting to revisit
it again and get deeper and deeper with
every rewatch I feel like I did when I
read it I didn't I I knew that it was
something that had so many questions in
it but I didn't feel any need to ask
Jane those questions because I knew that
like the questions would be answered by
meditating on the script and figuring
out how to believe in the world of the
script and the the characters and
figuring out the different worlds within
it and how I could make those worlds
real in my body so even though there
were things that maybe don't like make
sense I was thrilled by the parts that
didn't make sense because I'm always so
tired of like scripts that try to make
sense out of like fear and embarrassment
and I was really glad that Jane was so
bold in like not trying to explain uh
what really come down to like um very
complex and nuanced feelings that we can
all relate to so I knew that like they
would be in me if I just like looked for
them so given how you approach the work
here when you first signed on what
quality of mes were you most looking
forward to getting to explore but then
can you also pinpoint a quality that you
found along the way that wound up being
more creatively fulfilling to play with
than you could have imagined at the
start I think I felt in in Maddie's uh
journey in this film that there was a
point where she got to let out an
expression of pure rage but also pure
Bliss at being alive and getting to
connect with other people and getting to
understand uh yourself as this like
always moving changing like bundle of
ferocity and I was excited to um get to
that point but along the way there were
so many moments of like uh like I I
don't know this like this like shy like
but kind of like silly feeling like the
moments when Maddie really opens up like
when she starts talking about the pink
oque to Owen and like these moments of
like wonder that come over her I didn't
expect those and then when we got to set
and when I was working with with both
Ian and Justice like those moments felt
really alive I'm obsessed with the Pingo
pink yeah feel like the movie definitely
had that effect on me I have to let you
all go in a moment so I'll wrap with our
uh our filo question again it's a it's a
company that specializes in putting the
green light power in the hands of the
Creator so can you each recall a time
when someone gave you creative control
when maybe you didn't think you were
going to get it even though you deserved
it there's a con I guess a weird
conversation with like music where I
mean I I didn't sign to a label that was
um like evil Big Wigs or anything but
people talk about La like losing
creative control as a thing in music a
lot um and yeah I guess uh I guess like
working with a label that is creative
and cool um kind of exceeded my
expectations
about what the content has to be what it
has to sound like how many songs there
has to be um yeah they kind of just like
let me run wild and I I my impression of
the music industry is that or for is
that that's not like a thing that happen
so it's a nice surprise glad you have
that
thanks have about for you too anything
come to mind yeah I did a shoe for puss
puss magazine my friend Min and I and we
got to play these characters uh that we
perform live as silver and smoke and
they're a ghost Punk Duo and we wear
long blonde wigs and they're like really
like Mean Girls and we got to do the
whole shoot T them and like really be
like very demanding about everything we
wanted and so that was cool I like
that I think the God thing is what I
would go with um yeah I feel like
uh when I realized I could just uh build
my life the way I wanted to build it and
uh you know I got gave myself the green
light and here here we are at the
collider Studio collider Studio
presented by filo presented by God
and fil me out I mean I'll roll with
that too I'm going to say thank you for
your time today huge huge huge
congratulations on I saw the TV glow
these are the kinds of films that people
come to Sundance to see bold visions
that can only be made by a singular
director with a team that really
supports it behind them so huge
congratulations to everybody out there
keep an eye out for I saw the TV glow
and stay tuned we'll have more
interviews for you very
soon